صوره المعاناه من من شمال قطاع غزه من
مكان ما انا متواجد في لا ار ماء ولا
كهرباء ولا غذاء الماء الذي نستخدمه ملوث
جدا اغلب الوقت لا يوجد اتصالات الكهرباء
معدومه الغذاء البسكويت
فقط القصف هنا عشوائي وقنابل ضخمه جدا
ترعب وترهب عندما حدث عن النزوح لا يجد لا
يوجد وسيله تنقل الى جنوب قطاع غزه لا
يوجد وسيله وسيله
[تصفيق]
لتنقل انت شو اللي مخليك في منطقه شمال
غزه حتى الان اول شغله الاخبار اللي
بنسمعها عن وجود لا وجود لخط او ممر امن
كله بتم استهدافه والوجود اللي هو نقطه
تفتيش انه هي نقطه قش ممكن انت ياخذوك
لسبب او من دون سبب فهذا الممر بخليك انك
انت تقول لا بموت انا مره واحده احسن ما
اني انا امر على اموت على مراحل مره اموت
من الخوف ومره اموت من الجوع سواء كان
بالشمال او
بالجنوب ب نق لكم صوره الوضع في الشمال
والاهالي القانطين في الشمال قطاع غزه
اولها الوضع الصحي عننا كارثي هناك العديد
من الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ والمصابين
والجرحى اللي بيحتاجوا الى عنايه ضروريه
وفور وعاجله من ناحيه الماء بنعاني من ما
من نقص شديد في المياه واعتمادنا الكلي
على المياه الملوثه عدم خروجنا من بيوتنا
فهذا يعني بعود الى ثلاث او اربع اسباب
اهمها هو الوضع الامني بحيث تقوم الطائرات
المصيره بقصف المدنيين العزل عدم توافر
وسائل النقل عدم توفر سيارات لنقل الاهالي
والسبب الثالث هو حاله
من الناس الصامدين اللي ما بدهم يخرجوا من
بيوتهم هم اساسا لاجئين عام 48 فما بدهم
يعيشوا نكبه اهاليهم واللي طلعوا ما رجعوا
على بلادهم وسط مخيم جباليه بنايه سكنيه
قاعدين في مكان ما يم الله الله فيه مكان
خطير مكان كله قصف والله ما بنام الليل
الليل ما بنام واولادي حواليه مرعين من
القصف وخبط
الدبابات الله حرام عليهم حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل فيهم الدبابات من شقه والطيارات من
فوق روسنا احنا عارفين الاد عارفين يناموا
مقين في
تز طب انتم ليش ما تركتوا هذا المكان وين
نروح يا اب وين نروح محين من مكان لمكان
الشار من مكان لمكان ماليش مكان اقعد فيه
بنموت سوا بنعيش سوا انا واولادك خلص ماضل
فيها
قعد ولادي ومرتي قاعدين في البيت فجاه قصف
البيت علينا اصيبت زوج اصابه خطيره
واستشهدت بنتي البالغه من عمر ثلاث سنوات
ونصف والان زوجتي هي مصابه وفي مستشفى في
في مدينه غزه وسبل الوصول اليها صار مش
عارف اطم حالتها مش عارف ايش وضعها مش
قادر اصلها ولا اتحرك من مخيم جبالي او
اجي وين بدي اروح فيش اللي مكان ولا ماب
ولا شيء يعني عامل لي شويه خشيه شويه
شوادر وقاعد فيها انا وابني اللي ضايل معي
وين بدي اروح لاي قرايب في الجنوب ولا
بعرف حدا ولا اي شي لسه الناس احنا
موجودين مخيم جباليه وجباليا مليئه
بالسكان عايشين بحصار وبقله اكل وجبس ولكن